Bonjour et bienvenue dans cette vidéo en
collaboration avec Raphy, de la chaîne...
-Sweetberry. Mais pourquoi tu chuchotes?
-Parce qu'on est dans une bibliothèque, et
dans les bibliothèques il faut pas parler
fort.
-Ouais. Enfin j'ai pas signé pour une vidéo
en asmr, alors on va viiite rappeler qu'à
la base on pouvait très bien parler fort
et débattre dans les bibliothèques, et on
va faire pareil? D'accord?
-OK.
Bref, on a décidé avec Sweetberry de vous
parler des bibliothèques en mélangeant nos
spécialités respectives pour vous offrir
deux vidéos: celle-ci qui vous parlera
d'Histoire avec un peu de symboliques dedans...
-Et celle que vous retrouverez sur la chaîne
Sweetberry qui vous parlera de symbolique
avec un peu d'Histoire dedans.
-Voilà. Mais on vous en reparlera en fin
de vidéo.
Le mot «bibliothèque» vient du grec
et signifie d'abord l'armoire des livres,
juste le meuble avant de désigner par extension
la pièce où se trouve ce meuble.
Au MA on préfère employer le mot armarium
qui de la même manière désigne l'armoire
à livres, ou encore librarium qui désigne
l'armoire, vous avez compris. De là apparaissent
les mots armarius, la personne en charge des
livres, et librarius qui peut aussi faire
référence au moine copiste. Le mot bibliothèque,
enfin, s'impose définitivement au XVIIIe
siècle seulement.
Si on commence par l'Antiquité, ce qui paraît
logique, la bibliothèque d'Alexandrie est
LA référence qui parlera à tout le monde
mais ce n'est pas du tout la première.
Pour qu'il y ait des livres, il faut de l'écriture,
qui apparaît en Égypte et en Mésopotamie
vers 5000 av, et dès le milieu du IVe siècle
apparaissent les premiers dépôts de textes
qui sont plutôt des archives à tablettes
et autres papyrus. Il n'y a pas d'idée de
conservation, l'intérêt de ces dépôts
est plutôt pratique et sert à une poignée
de scribes et dignitaires capables de les
lire.
On peut quand même citer la bibliothèque
du roi assyrien Assurbanipal qui comptait
environ 30 000 tablettes dont certaines parlant
de littérature, de religion, de sciences,
de divination...
En Égypte l'écriture est elle aussi réservée
au palais et aux scribes, donc on trouve surtout
les bibliothèques dans les temples où on
les appelle «maisons des livres» ou
dans les palais. Quand elles ont une vocation
plus universelle, traitant de littérature
et de sciences et possédant des ateliers
d'écriture, on les appelle «maisons de
vie». On trouve par exemple la bibliothèque
royale de Gizeh, dès le milieu du IIIe millénaire.
Avec les grecs et surtout les philosophes
grecs, la littérature se développe. Platon
fonde une Académie qui possède des livres,
Aristote aussi, et on en arrive à Alexandrie,
super centre financier, culturel, the place
to be où est fondé le Musée.
Ouais, la bibliothèque s'appelle le Musée
en fait. La demeure des muses. On y trouve
des professeurs, des copistes, des chercheurs,
des œuvres d'art... Son objectif est de conserver
un exemplaire de toutes les œuvres existantes
à l'époque, rien que ça. De préférence
en grec et dans la meilleure traduction possible,
d'où la présence de copistes. Elle aurait
possédé jusque 700 000 exemplaires ainsi
que des tables de classification permettant
de s'y retrouver, montrant que son but n'était
pas seulement de posséder tous les livres
mais aussi d'en permettre l'accès à ceux
qui le voulaient.
Tout ça fait d'Alexandrie un centre scientifique,
avec même d'autres dépôts et bibliothèques
spécialisées, mais qui sont progressivement
détruits par des incendies, dont l'un est
déclenché par César, veni vidi vici, troubles
politiques, jusqu'à la conquête arabe du
VIIe siècle qui achève de disperser et faire
disparaître cette somme monumentale de connaissances.
Les bibliothèques sont aussi variées dans
les films que dans le réel. Certaines sont
à taille humaine et d’autres digne de l’Olympe.
Ca tombe bien, parlons des bibliothèques
utilisant le style architectural de l’antiquité
dans les flims.
Déjà, on peut remarquer que ce sont plus
les films américains qui ont ce genre de
bâtiment. Il y aura forcément des contres
exemples comme la bibliothèque dans Indiana
Jones et le temple maudit.
Mais pour les US, la mémoire est quelque
chose d’important mais surtout sa différence
avec le vieux continent. La nation américaine,
entendez par là, les immigrés du vieux continent,
a besoin de reconnaître sa propre valeur.
Née bien plus tard dans l’histoire, elle
a comme une sorte de complexe vis à vis de
l’histoire plus longue du vieux continent.
Et pour cause.
Construire de tel bâtiment pour garder la
mémoire de ce “nouveau pays” (entre guillemet)
permet aux US de renouer avec l’Histoire
mondiale (enfin celle qu’ils ont été forcé
d’abandonner pour la plupart).
Des bâtiments qui possèdent des colonnes
grecques, des chapiteaux romains et semblent
tout droit sorti d’un ensemble de temple
voué à une ancienne divinité, c’est montré
la puissance du savoir et de la mémoire pour
la ville. Ce genre de bâtiment c’est aussi
l’assurance du clinquant, de la force et
du prestige. Des symboles qui sont liés souvent
à l’antiquité.
Ces bâtiments imposent par leur stature,
ils sont gigantesques par rapport au reste.
Via les grecs, la culture du livre s'est répandue
à Rome: les maisons distinguées devaient
posséder une bibliothèque chez elles, même
dans les villae de campagne, confisquer des
livres après une victoire était la base
mais ces collections de livres restent limitées
à la famille et aux amis.
Sénèque dénonce même ce goût pour les
livres qui en fait monter le prix à cause
de collectionneurs riches mais ignorants et
qui ne les liront finalement jamais.
Le premier à imaginer une bibliothèque publique
à Rome est Jules César, elle est fondée
en 39 av, et suivie d'autres fondations des
empereurs suivants. Fréquenter la bibliothèque
devient alors banal et on peut même déjà
y emprunter des livres, mais elles restent
un lieu retreint à ceux qui ont déjà une
bonne formation intellectuelle. A l'époque,
pas question de chuchoter: on trouve dans
ces bâtiments des salles de spectacles, on
discute, on travaille aussi... Mais à cause
de destructions et de la fragilité des papyrus,
on ne garde presque rien des connaissances
qu'elles renfermaient. Et puis y'a une autre
raison, mais ça, j'en parle chez Raphy. Alors
allez-y.
Mais revenons-en à l'histoire des bibliothèques:
l'arrivée de peuples barbares en occident
entraîne de nombreuses destructions, et l'arrivée
du christianisme fait que les quelques bibliothèques
comme celles de Césarée ou de Bethléem
sont surtout consacrées aux livres religieux.
Les premiers moines voient d'un mauvais œil
le fait de posséder beaucoup de livres, ils
voient d'un mauvais œil le fait de posséder
beaucoup de quoi que ce soit de toute façon,
et il faut attendre le VIe siècle pour qu'une
bibliothèque sur le modèle de celle d'Alexandrie
réapparaisse. Il s'agit de la bibliothèque
de Vivarium, qui rassemble une centaine de
manuscrits, on a légèrement revu les ambitions
à la baisse, dont certains écrits grecs
qu'elle recopie. Le catalogue de Vivarium
devient LA référence de livres à posséder
dans chaque bibliothèque: les monastères
commencent à posséder des livres aussi,
et à développer leur activité de copie.
A partir du Xe siècle l'usage de l'écrit
se développe un peu dans certaines professions.
Faisons aussi un petit point arabo-musulman,
puisque les grandes villes comme Bagdad, le
Caire, Cordoue et même Tombouctou, dans l'actuel
Mali, ont de très importantes bibliothèques
qui inspirent l'Occident: c'est en voyant
celle de Tunis, pendant sa croisade, que saint-Louis
décide de faire son copieur et d'en avoir
une aussi dans son palais. Certains auteurs
antiques sont aussi redécouverts aux Xe et
XIe siècle en Occident via leurs traductions
arabes.
Dans la deuxième moitié du MA on a donc
plusieurs types de bibliothèques:
-Les bibliothèques dans les abbayes, où
on trouve des livres, des moines, et des copistes,
le tout joyeusement rassemblé dans le scriptorium
sur lequel on reviendra juste après.
-Les bibliothèques princières qui connaissent
un grand engouement à partir de Charles V
qui développe énormément le concept en
se dotant de 3900 livres, et qui inspire d'autres
princes à avoir leur propre bibliothèque.
Les ducs de Bourgogne par exemple pour ne
pas les citer.
-Et puis des bibliothèques privées plus
petites chez certains juristes ou médecins,
des bibliothèques universitaires... En tout
cas ce qu'il faut retenir du Moyen Âge c'est
que l'usage des livres se répand même s'ils
restent trèèèèès chers, et surtout la
quasi exclusivité des livres religieux prend
fin et s'ouvre à des auteurs arabes et antiques.
C'est maintenant le moment de casser toutes
les images que vous aviez probablement en
tête quand je vous parlais de scriptoriums,
de copistes et de bibliothèques, puisque
c'est le thème: les salles avec des pupitres,
des livres partout et des toiles d'araignée
dans les coins n'apparaissent pas avant le
XIIIe siècle. Et encore, pour les toiles
d'araignées c'est pas sourcé.
Le nombre de livres possédé par chaque monastère
reste généralement tellement faible qu'il
n'est pas dans l'usage d'avoir une salle à
part. La Sorbonne, par exemple, est l'une
des plus développées en 1338 et possède
338 livres consultables, 1728 dans ses registres
dont 300 déclarés perdus. Les collections
européennes comptaient en moyenne une centaine
de livres, mille dans le meilleur des cas,
alors que certaines collections chinoises
atteignaient 100 000 rouleaux, on n'en parle
pas assez sur cette chaîne alors big up à
la civilisation chinoise.
Dans ces conditions, la bibliothèque est
le coin où on range les livres, généralement
un coffre où les livres sont enveloppés
dans des couvertures ou plus tardivement une
armoire en bois. Idem pour les collections
privées. On ne regroupe pas non plus tous
les livres au même endroit: certains sont
dans l'église pour la messe, d'autres dans
le réfectoire pour la lecture, et le reste
dans le cloître où on installe les copistes
dans un coin.
Avec le développement des collections, la
situation évolue au XIIIe siècle: on crée
une «salle des livres» accessible uniquement
au bibliothécaire, et un scriptorium dédié
pour les copistes dans une galerie surélevée
pour protéger les livres et les moines de
l'humidité du cloître.
C'est ce type de scriptorium qu'on retrouve
dans Le Nom de la Rose, même si la salle
des livres y est un peu hors normes: personne
n'a le droit d'y entrer sauf le bibliothécaire
et son assistant, et une partie des livre
est stockée directement dans le scriptorium,
sur des pupitres.
Les pupitres n'étaient pas seulement des
meubles de travail mais servaient au rangement
des livres à partir du XIIIe siècle. Les
livres y étaient souvent enchaînés, pour
éviter les vols vu leur valeur, et certains
donateurs posaient même l'enchaînement des
livres comme condition pour offrir leur livre
à la bibliothèque.
Même une grande bibliothèque comme celle
du Vatican, fondée au XVe siècle, possède
pour tout rangement des armoires, des coffres
et des pupitres. Pas de rayonnages ni d'échelles
pour y accéder. Désolé.
Ce sont aussi des lieux de mémoire : on y
garde la trace des ancien.nes. Dans des dystopies
de science fiction qui se déroulent dans
le futur, on peut y voir parfois des bibliothèques
qui tombent en ruine. C’est un message fort
: la mémoire se perd dans la déchéance
du monde et donc des humain.es. Après, c’est
sur qu’entre sauver ta peau contre des zombies
par exemple ou des aliens et sauver la biblio,
le choix est vite vu !
La mémoire que la bibliothèque garde est
une sorte de représentation de ce que doit
être la civilisation. Si on ne garde pas
la mémoire, il n’y a pas de civilisation.
Bon, c’est un point de vu un peu réducteur
mais on le retrouve pas mal. On reste dans
la notion de victoire contre la sauvagerie
de la nature.
C’est souvent là où les héros.ïnes trouvent
les réponses d’une énigme.
Il y a un symbole qui s’attache à la bibliothèque
est celui du savoir sans limite. Il existe
des représentations de bibliothèque labyrinthique
où il y a aurait tous les savoirs du monde.
Dans le Nom de la Rose, la bibliothèque est
un labyrinthe et l’on comprend tout de suite
que cette bibliothèque est spéciale et qu’elle
renferme des ouvrages hors-normes. Cela revient
à cette volonté de dompter la nature, la
bibliothèque peut contenir tout le savoir
du monde et ce, depuis la nuit des temps.
Le souvenir humain ne sera jamais perdu, enfin
c’est ce qui est espéré.
Au milieu du XVe siècle apparaît une petite
nouveauté dont vous avez peut-être entendu
parler et qui s'appelle l'imprimerie. Cette
invention n'est pas retentissante tout de
suite parce que son premier but est de reproduire
des manuscrits, avant de créer de nouveaux
livres uniquement imprimés: les princes
continuent de préférer des manuscrits parce
que c'est plus classe et leur bibliothèque
se remplit d'imprimés plus à cause de cadeaux
ou de dons que via leur achat. Les imprimés
ne dominent définitivement qu'à la fin du
XVIIe siècle.
Les abbayes et lecteurs privés, par contre,
en achètent un peu plus rapidement parce
que c'est pas cher.
C'est à cette époque qu'apparaît une nouvelle
sorte de bibliothèque privée chez les humanistes:
ils forment des bibliothèques bien fournies,
et invitent tous leurs amis à venir les lire
parce que jusque là l'idée de partage et
de transfert de connaissances n'était pas
hyper présente. Fernand Colomb, par exemple,
le fils de Christophe Colomb constitue une
bibliothèque de 15 000 volumes et reçoit
même une rente royale pour son entretien
alors que c'était une initiative privée.
Certaines villes, Florence la première, reprennent
cette idée: à la fin du XIVe siècle un
groupe d'humanistes locaux fonde une bibliothèque
publique, une vraie. Dans le reste de l'Europe
certains princes ouvrent leur bibliothèque
aux savants et lecteurs qui voudraient en
profiter, même si je doute que le premier
pécore venu y aurait été vu d'un bon œil.
Les choses changent aussi au niveau du mobilier:
durant le Moyen Âge les bibliothèques avaient
peu de livres, mais ils prenaient de la place:
sur un mètre de long on pouvait poser trois
manuscrits, à plat pour pas les abîmer,
alors qu'on peut mettre 20 à 40 livres debout!
Ils risquent plus de se péter!
Du coup adieu coffres et bonjour... Armoires.
A la fin du XVIe siècle apparaissent les
bibliothèques à stalles en Angleterre, dont
Oxford ou Cambridge offrent un très bon exemple,
mais dans le reste de l'Europe on adopte le
système mural: la plus ancienne bibliothèque
de ce style est l'Escorial, construite fin
XVIe, la première grande pièce tapissée
de livres placés dans des armoires grillagées
pour éviter les vols. Mais pour la première
fois: on voit les livres. Les rayonnages
muraux apparaissent rapidement, et avec eux
les échelles ou galeries intermédiaires
telles que toutes les bibliothèques anciennes
que vous avez déjà vues.
Vous constaterez si vous avez bien suivi que
je me suis arrêtée au XVIIe siècle. Si
vous voulez connaître la fin de l'histoire
des bibliothèques, je vous invite à enchaîner
sur la vidéo de Raphy dans laquelle on parlera
des bibliothèques modernes et de leurs symboles
au cinéma. Et si vous avez regardé cette
vidéo en 2e, bravo, vous savez maintenant
tout sur
les bibliothèques et pourrez crâner auprès
de vos amis.
Conclusion en impro.